President Biden is back in Washington
after his trip to London for the Queen's
funeral with a long list of things to do
he's expecting a big decision on one of
his top economic issues and at the same
time he has important business to do
with other world leaders Nancy Cordes is
at the White House Nancy good morning
good morning Michelle the president does
have a packed week he's leaving this
afternoon for New York to address the
annual UN General Assembly and when he
is there tomorrow morning he will speak
to world leaders and Ukraine of course
will be a major focus of the Gathering
now when it comes to domestic concerns
inflation remains a key priority for
this white house and there's going to be
big news on that front as well this week
the Federal Reserve begins meeting today
with an expected interest rate kite
coming tomorrow it's anticipated the FED
will raise rates by another three
quarters of a percentage Point making it
the central bank's fifth increase this
year as it attempts to combat inflation
by slowing the economy this decision
could mean higher rates for things like
credit cards mortgages and auto loans
and it comes amid warnings that the
interest rate hikes themselves could
spark a recession something that we'll
all be watching in the weeks ahead Tony
yeah they may have to hurt the economy
to help the economy long term Nancy
thank you very much we'll have more on
that tomorrow I'm sure